[Music]
on this sunday night deadly tornadoes in
december
the desperate search for survivors in
six american states walls feel like they
was caving in our jackson prosco is in
kentucky reporting on the devastation
alberta eases holiday restrictions as
ontario sees a big rise in coven 19
cases canada and its allies show a
united front to stop russia from
invading ukraine you are a killer louie
and remembering the author of the
vampire chronicles and rice dead at the
age of 80.
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us a desperate search for survivors is
underway in the u.s midwest after one of
the deadliest tornado events in american
history at least 90 people were killed
during an unusual mid-december swarm of
storms that leveled entire communities
the damage is devastating
the entire
blocks
more than one block
with nothing standing we have over
300 guardsmen that are active they're
doing everything from going door to door
though in many of these communities we
don't have doors anymore
they're going rebel to
to rubble
at least 30 tornadoes were reported
across six states twisters touched down
in arkansas illinois missouri
mississippi tennessee and kentucky these
before and after satellite pictures of a
candle factory in mayfield kentucky say
it all it is completely gone more than
100 employees were working there at the
time our jackson proskow is in mayfield
tonight where a desperate rescue
operation is underway jackson
robin everywhere you look in the town of
mayfield there is damage just like this
you see overturned vehicles and
flattened buildings homes that are
completely gone the industrial park is
gone the city center is gone here in
mayfield and it is going to take a very
long time to recover from this but of
course the immediate focus is on the
scores of people who are still missing
including at that candle factory where
the night shift was underway when the
tornado struck dozens of people were
rescued but there are dozens more still
missing and the governor says at this
point finding anyone alive in that
wreckage would be an absolute miracle
and yet the work continues we've seen
rescue crews going door to door here in
the community we're also seeing
residents sift through the rubble of
their own homes trying to salvage what
few personal belongings may have
survived the tornado this is a community
effort but there is a lot of concern
about the future here i spoke with one
local a lifelong resident he's actually
a lawyer here in town his practice was
wiped clean off its foundations he was
trying to salvage client documents and
he says he's not only concerned about
the immediate future but also about the
long term of a town that has been
completely wiped off the map
obviously disbelief
in a way it's just
you look at it and like
that really can't be real you know but
but it is and uh
so we were pretty stunned but then i you
know shortly thereafter it's like you
kind of go into this mode okay what's
next that's
you know it's hard
it's hard to think anything i mean i
i'm just so overwhelmed with
lots of emotions and one sadness that
it's happened
gratefulness that you know look at all
the people helping us that we didn't
even know them before today
time is certainly not on the side of the
rescue crews here the weather is growing
colder at night and of course there is
no power there is no water in this
community many of the residents have
been forced to find other places to stay
because their homes are simply
uninhabitable at this point this is a
cleanup effort that is going to take
months if not years and will likely
result in wide swaths of this town
having to be rebuilt from scratch rob
and the scale of this is unimaginable
and we know it is on track to become one
of the worst tornado outbreaks in
american history at this point
so unbelievable jackson prosco in
mayfield kentucky
so many homes and businesses have been
destroyed across several states
president joe biden has deployed the
national guard and federal emergency
workers to help people rebuild their
lives jennifer johnson continues our
coverage tonight grief and pain in the
small town of mayfield kentucky as
residents pray for the dead and call on
more survivors to be found
religious leaders trying to heal a
community that has lost lives and
livelihoods i've seen a lot of things in
my life from policing to ministry but
this is the worst absolutely the worst
this was one of the most violent storms
to ever hit the u.s one enormous and
terrifying tornado stayed on the ground
for over four hours tearing apart
everything in its path i've never seen
anything like that in fact there's only
ever been two tornadoes in history that
have tracked that far
entire communities have been destroyed
thousands of people have lost their
homes and businesses most people can't
believe they survived the windows
started breaking dogs flying through the
air
i didn't know what to do walls felt like
they was caving in it was very scary
six people were killed at this illinois
amazon facility built with thick
concrete walls less than five years ago
workers had little warning the tornado
was about to hit i had a co-worker that
was sending me pictures when they were
taking shelter in the bathroom
basically anywhere they could hide
nearby neighbors took cover too in utter
shock they lived through it if you don't
believe in god you need to come talk to
me
before and after satellite pictures show
this arkansas nursing home wiped away
one person died and five others were
seriously injured
governors of the hardest-hit states
toward damaged areas pledging state and
federal aid at a time most people should
be celebrating christmas especially
during holiday seasons you hate to see
this kind of thing happen you hate to
see people lose their homes
at a time like this
the cleanup will take months but it will
be decades and generations before anyone
forgets the force and destruction of
these unusual december tornadoes
jennifer johnson global news washington
the same violent storm slammed into
canada yesterday with wicked winds
clocking 100 kilometers an hour those
gusts knock down trees and electricity
poles wiping out power grids in quebec
and ontario crews are scrambling to
restore power to hundreds of thousands
of people there is extensive damage
across the two provinces hydro quebec
says the wind storm left more than 300
000 customers without power hydro one in
ontario says more than 200 000 customers
have been affected
turning to the pandemic ontario is
reporting its highest daily case count
since may there are more than 1400 new
cases in that province today eight more
people have died from the virus of the
new cases 612 are among people who are
not fully vaccinated the omicron variant
makes up 11 of infections in the
province
albertans still don't know what kind of
holiday gatherings will be allowed under
the province's covet rules and christmas
is just two weeks away the current
restrictions are some of the toughest in
the country but they are set to be
relaxed this week heather york's west
looks at the risks heading into the
holidays with the threat of the new
variant it'll be nice six-year-old indy
and four-year-old sloan are excited for
christmas a christmas their mom hopes
will feel more normal than last year
quiet very quiet it was just the four of
us and my husband made a full turkey
dinner for all of us which was really
sweet but different they're not the only
ones eager to expand their holiday guest
list so is alberta's premiere i can tell
you my own family i'll be gathering with
uh with
three family members uh all together us
we're all fully vaccinated we come from
three households only four people but we
wouldn't be able to do that christmas
based on the current rules rules kenny
was hesitant to impose in the first
place after alberta's best summer ever
gave way to a punishing fourth wave in
the fall the province has been slower to
ease private gathering restrictions at
the moment a fully vaccinated albertan
can only gather with one other household
up to a maximum of 10 people that's the
toughest gathering rule in the country
the province plans to ease those
restrictions this week there are no
province-wide gathering restrictions in
bc though two health regions within the
province have imposed limits
particularly for those not fully
vaccinated manitoba also has gathering
limits for only those without two doses
of vaccine while nova scotia ontario and
quebec have opted to put a cap on the
number of people who can gather
privately for christmas it's 25 in nova
scotia and ontario 20 in quebec i'm just
feeling really cautious about the whole
thing i just think no one wants another
wave and so
i'm hoping that we see people keep
keeping things kind of reasonably
buttoned down over the next while
alberta has seen daily covid19 infection
numbers fall since the peak of the
fourth wave but intensive care units are
still operating beyond normal capacity
relying on temporary surge beds the
premier says the province is watching
those numbers carefully i'm hoping for
normal christmas with plans to host
their holiday meal this year the
maskewich family are among those
anxiously waiting to see what alberta's
new rules will be heather urex west
global news calgary
this week the trudeau government is set
to update canadians on the health of
national finances tomorrow deputy prime
minister and minister of finance
christopher freeland is slated to
announce a new five-year deal on
inflation control with the bank of
canada on tuesday freeland will present
the fiscal update in ottawa in it the
federal government is expected to share
details on coven 19's support and
continued pandemic recovery it will also
touch on benefits and proposed tax
measures
today canada and its allies warned
russian president vladimir putin that
there will be massive consequences if
ukraine is attacked there are reports
russia is building up its military and
missile deployment at the border between
the two countries as michael couture
reports the g7 is demanding the kremlin
de-escalate immediately
foreign ministers of g7 countries
including canada forming a united front
against russia the focus of talks at a
gathering in liverpool england have
largely focused on the ramped up
military presence of russian troops on
its border with ukraine we've been clear
that any incursion by russia into
ukraine would have massive consequences
for which there would be a severe cost
saturday u.s president joe biden who
spoke with russia's vladimir putin
earlier this week was even more direct
i've made it absolutely clear president
putin that
if he moves on ukraine
the economic consequences for his
economy are going to be devastating
devastating
a ramping up of rhetoric is being felt
across europe with the vatican calling
for calm
pope emperor prayed for ukraine asking
that tensions be resolved through
serious international dialogue and not
with weapons a moscow's latest buildup
of troops and military equipment is
along the border of eastern ukraine near
an area largely controlled by
russian-backed separatists the
cross-border tensions are a reminder of
what happened in 2014 when putin annexed
crimea
at that time western nations imposed
crippling sanctions on russia and
they're threatening to do the same again
but observers say one big difference is
western nations weren't taken by
surprise this time so we shouldn't
expect a matching of military might the
message here is we will not fight you
but we will
raise the costs of any further
aggression
but statement points out putin is
unpredictable and at this point his end
goal is unclear
he's not a chess master
he's a judo artist and that means that
he just looks for individual
opportunities to strike not really
thinking five steps ahead and what
nato's and the g7 are doing is trying to
signal that this one step is too costly
on its own so now the world waits to see
if putin heeds that warning
mike licouter global news ottawa
coming up cracks are discovered in
canada's new navy choppers already over
budget and the memorable mega city male
who had his share of missteps
[Applause]
there are questions tonight about the
military's navy helicopters known as the
cyclones a crack was discovered in one
chopper and further inspections found
the same problem in 18 other helicopters
as ross lord reports there is growing
concern about the future of the fleet
over budget by a couple of billion
dollars and 10 years later than expected
some of canada's new navy helicopters
still haven't gone into service now the
sikorsky made cyclone helicopters are in
the repair shop after cracks were
discovered on the tail sections of 19 of
the 23 choppers
for machines that are constantly
vibrating cracks are bad news as crews
inspect and repair the cyclones one by
one their absence from service is
already being felt they were unable to
join the relief effort during the bc
floods and there are concerns about how
effective they'll be when they resume
flying in their main job as the eyes and
ears of canadian navy frigates the
question now is whether
replacement parts i gather there are
some in inventory
uh are reliable
uh to send the aircraft up on a full
spectrum of missions you know types of
things they do
or whether they have to impose safety
limitations the department of national
defense says the location of the tail
section cracks are unique for each
aircraft which some pilots fear will
make it harder to pinpoint the cause and
source of the cracking it could very
well be related
to the fact that there is a folding tail
configuration which is unique to the
cyclone and not to other variants so
they're obviously not affected or not
required to have an inspection done on
them this in the aftermath of last
year's cyclone crash near greece which
killed all six occupants
investigations found the helicopter's
autopilot took control of the aircraft
as the pilot was turning to land on a
nearby frigate in a statement sikorsky
says the cracks do not pose an immediate
safety hazard the company says it's
working hard with the military to
complete repairs although there's no
official timeline
ross lord global news
still ahead the indigenous community
leads the bid for the olympics in
vancouver
you're watching global national
in british columbia four first nations
that came together for the 2010
vancouver olympics want to do it all
over again this time they're exploring
the idea of their own bid for the 2030
winter games the city and province would
have to be on board and as nitu garcia
reports if it all comes together it
would be an historic first
we're going to explore
the feasibility of an indigenous
led olympic games
this is the start of what could be a
world first an indigenous lead olympics
this is really
a moment in history a legend being made
leaders from the lil watt musqueam
squamish and slaywood tooth nations
signing a memorandum of understanding
with the city of vancouver and resort
municipality of whistler everybody knows
that this is our territory you know
the acknowledgement that we're getting
from the world is
unbelievable today storytelling would be
a critical part of the games says chief
of the lil want nation we're still under
the internet we're still living on
reservations and yeah it's a very
glorified
place to be in the olympics and stuff
but to to truly understand the
relationship we had differences between
our nations
and it was 2010 that brought us back
together again
before the prospect of this happening
again in bc becomes real a feasibility
study is planned an official bid could
follow late next year with costs in the
billions how is this going to be
feasible for for our nations to be a
part of but also you know it comes down
to the cost climate change
considerations are also key because of
what's happening with the floods
wildfires and as indigenous people we
have we have laws about protecting the
land
snow had to be trucked in for the 2010
games and research suggests the region's
mountains could have even less by 2030.
so you can see that we're getting a lot
more of the snow
as rain and average temperatures are
slowly moving up it's about how we as
settlers can reshape how we live on
these unceded lands it's a privilege to
put my shoulder behind this
investigation and this effort
first nations leaders with a lot to
consider say this announcement alone is
an important step i think this is a big
part of reconciliation
nitu garcia global news vancouver
up next the toronto mayor who called in
the military and caught the attention of
a nation
[Music]
and her suffering and yours
that 1994 blockbuster interview with a
vampire was based on anne rice's first
novel written in 1976. tonight people
around the world are remembering the
author who died yesterday following
complications from a stroke the gothic
writer who was born in new orleans spun
that first book into a series of vampire
chronicles it sold more than
million copies worldwide anne rice was
80 years old
tonight people in toronto are looking
back at the life of the mega city's
first mayor mel lassman he died
yesterday at the age of 88 at the time
of his reign the amalgamation of six
municipalities was controversial and so
was the man who took the helm the rest
of the country may remember how he
pushed the spice girls to reunite and
called in the army during a snowstorm as
matthew bingley reports there were many
other moments that put him in the
political spotlight
[Music]
the bad boy appliance entrepreneur
turned millionaire turned long-time
politician but according to mel lassman
himself he wasn't one for grand titles
everybody's calling me mel you know i'm
not mr mayor i'm not mayor mel or i'm
not mayor of last month i'm mel that's
all they call me and that's terrific it
might as well have been mayor mel
lassman won several straight mayoral
elections beginning in north york
followed by toronto where he became the
first to take the helm of the
amalgamated megacity in 1998. welcome to
the new city of toronto managing it
wasn't easy and last min soon found
himself squaring off against then
premier mike harris over provincial
downloading fees mr premier you
lied never one to shy away from sharing
what was on his mind you say stupid and
dumb thing i mean what do you what do
you want from me except i'm sorry it was
his affinity for colorful and sometimes
insensitive language that often saw him
choking down humble pie scandals and
political gaffes aside lassman will
forever be known as the mayor who called
in the army after successive blizzards
crippled toronto in 1999 we will not
allow
this city
to be closed down even after enduring
two decades worth of mockery from the
rest of the country he still had no
regrets i will always
and i have always been safe
rather than sorry
like mayors before him lassman leaves a
permanent mark on this city his namesake
square sits outside north york civic
center
lastman walked away from politics in
2003 spending his retirement with his
wife of 70 years maryland retirement
is my wife was always looking after me
now
i'm there to look after her marilyn last
been passed away in 2020 before exiting
his role as mayor lassman offered this
advice which would turn out to be
prophetic if any mayor wants to make
their way
as the as
the mayor of toronto i think they have
to say it exactly as it is melvin
douglas lassman dead at 88. matthew
bingley global news
as a reporter i can tell you you never
knew what was going to come out of mel's
mouth
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is a tugboat decked out for the
holidays in the shipyards district of
north vancouver we'd love to see your
corner of the country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
and i'll see you next weekend good night
[Music]
you